all right this next story is a very big
deal
the january 6 trump riot committee the
committee investigating the january 6
2021 trump riots
is uh quite frankly doing a very good
job of something that is very difficult
there are so many different aspects to
the trump riots
what was trump up to in the time leading
up to
what was going on within law enforcement
what were trump's kids doing what were
members of the house doing what were
members of the senate doing who knew
what when
um
etc records that need to be obtained all
these different things
the
um last two weeks
have generated new evidence for the
committee because donald trump's
reaction to the committee's actions
now appeared to be witness tampering and
in fact congressman pete aguilar
said on cnn yesterday trump is tampering
with witnesses which is again scaling up
the criminality potential of what donald
trump has been up to so we have a cnn
report about this
january 6th committee member says trump
absolutely
tampering with witnesses as he continues
to dangle pardons let's take a look at
uh this video clip here
that that lawyer represents other
january six defendants and said that
rhodes and others would welcome a trump
pardon is trump tampering with witnesses
when he's talking about pardons when
he's dangling them in front of 1-6
defendants
absolutely and i think the question is
more for my colleagues on the other side
of the aisle you know where where are
they do they support this
when is enough enough when a mob is
chanting hang mike pence it wasn't
enough when the former president asked
brad raffensberger to find him 11 000
votes it wasn't enough right um now he's
you know dangling
pardons if he gets back in office for
individuals will that be enough or will
there be more collective amnesia
you know i just don't know where the
floor is these days on that where is the
floor and what is the bottom or however
it is that that you want to describe it
and what's being referred to here and
what's funny is this isn't even the
first time
that donald trump is dangling pardons in
a way that could be seen as witness
tampering remember that back with um
during the russia probe where you had
paul manafort
uh carter page
roger stone all these different people
being investigated and interviewed and
many subsequently charged uh for lying
to the fbi or different things donald
trump did the exact same thing he talked
about those who are staying strong
and he talked in a circuitous sort of
roundabout way about the possibility of
pardons
it could have been argued at that point
and many legal experts did argue that's
a form of witness tampering you were
signaling to these individuals if you
don't cooperate
i may pardon you in the future if you
don't cooperate there may be good things
coming and if you do cooperate you're
going to be on the list of bad boys so
to speak and you're not no longer going
to be in my good graces or whatever the
case may be
here donald trump is doing a very
similar thing with the trump rioters
themselves it's different because
there's a really good chance trump is
never going to pardon any of them and
and this is sort of like multi-step
it's not at all clear that donald trump
will be the republican nominee in 2024.
if he is the republican nominee it's not
at all clear that donald trump will win
the presidential election in 2024 if
trump wins the 2024 president
presidential election there is no
guarantee that he will actually pardon
any of these people
uh and so not only is it another attempt
to potentially influence the behavior of
the writers
and of those and this is an important
addition it's not only about influencing
the behavior of the rioters themselves
in their cases but also of republicans
more so in the house but in theory in
the house and senate and other people
around trump in general about
cooperation with the committee or the
trump rights it's a bigger signal
but
it's not even clear that trump really
intends to follow through on this and
you can you can make the argument as
pete aguilar does
on cnn that it is a form of witness
tampering now the obvious question is
well so should we expect a criminal
referral to the department of justice um
it and it is not because donald trump
will go to prison i maintain trump is
not going to prison but at what point do
we say
the facts just point to there should be
a criminal referral from the january 6
committee to the department of justice
and then put it on the department of
justice to decide
we will or won't investigate we will or
won't charge put it on merit garland to
actually
sort of be pushed into having to do
something when it comes to this when is
enough enough and um consider with
hillary clinton visa v benghazi
endless hearings special investigation
hearing report all these different
things
demanding charges demanding hillary
clinton be locked up absent any charges
ignoring their stated principle of the
value of due process and
constitutionality and the rule of law
and law and order and all these things
there wasn't even anything there and
they were saying lock up hillary clinton
it seems at minimum here uh there is
more than enough uh evidence and factual
basis for a criminal referral to the
department of justice and then let's see
how the department of justice deals with
it
um i don't expect this to stop
and we continue to follow the now more
than 700 cases 700 defendants
in the trump riots now 13 almost 13
months to the day beyond that date the
sentences are starting to come in
and we we will see where it ends up but
without a doubt this is arguably another
instance of witness tampering and if
you're trump
if there were no repercussions to the
earlier witness tampering with the
russia probe
why would you behave any differently now
of course you wouldn't and that's part
of this entire thing we'll have that
clip of congressman pete aguilar um on
our instagram you can find that at david
pakman's show we're going to take a
quick break and uh we've got a really
interesting interview coming up not
about the one percent but about the 9.9
percent what does that mean it's a very
interesting group culturally and
economically
and we're going to talk about that after
this short break
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door ready to eat no
cooking no cleaning dishes saves you a
lot of time you can choose from over 50
hot and cold meal options there's
smoothies grain and noodle bowls soups
i'm a big soup guy many of you know that
i also really liked the vegan meatballs
with marinara noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good for helping the
environment the list goes on i'm not
vegan you all know that i think but
splendid spoon is really great to just
help me maximize the proportion of
plants in my diet splendid spoon takes
all of the work out of tasty healthy
plant-based meals and you'll save 35
dollars when you go to splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below